The last conic section we'll learn about is a parabola. Parabolas only have one
part to their graph. Circles on the other hand have two parts to their graph.
And the reason they have two parts is because we have an x squared term and we
have a y squared term. Ellipses also have two parts to their graph. And again,
notice that the equation for the ellipse has an x squared term and it also has
a y squared term. And finally, we saw the hyperbola. The hyperbola also has two
parts to its graph. And notice, in the equation, we have the x squared term and
we have the y squared term. But a parabola only has one piece. The parabola can
either open up or down, or the parabola can open left or right. Each of these
is one graph. Of one parabola. These two equations are the general equations
that describe parabolas. This one describes parabolas that open up or down, and
notice that it's y equals. This equation describes parabolas that open to the
left and that open to the right. And notice that it starts with x equals.
Throughout this lesson, we'll learn more about each of these values and what
they do to the graph. But for now, let's take a look at the most basic
parabola. y equals x squared.